[Music]
we all grow up fantasizing about finding
true love with a knight in shining armor
and living happily ever after but that's
all it is fantasy are you okay
fear not I've been thrown much further
by much faster horses than your steel
steed not a scratch on that apparently
he believes that he's a 14th century
Knight so called Christopher Frederick
Lyons of March at your service oh boy
this is all my fault
where are they playing that lyrical
medley on the radio I'm going to help
him till his memory comes back what if
she's dangerous trust me he's harmless
first thing I think we should do is
update your wardrobe I at least a few
centuries greetings greetings I'll let
you get dressed you know time travel
isn't a real thing right I have traveled
here and it matters not if I understand
how
and I just want a valor and virtue will
give aid to those who seek but I fear I
must have turned him do you really think
going along with his little delusion is
helping a situation who are we to tell
him he's not who he says he is you sure
you're not a witch
but if Kol really is who he says he is
what if there are things beyond our
comprehension then I would say you both
need to get your heads examined you
don't have to go I have no choice
[Music]
wherever you are in any place I want to
be but no one can control their own
destiny nice catch
steady now milady
[Music]